welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my flash season 6 episode 3
video there were a whole bunch of crisis
on Infinite Earths
Easter eggs they even snuck in some
Shazam Black Adam Easter eggs so we'll
break it all down these came forward a
little bit yeah
come back there's a new round of the DC
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
we'll do top 10 and Easter eggs like
normal just careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet before we
get into it starting with number 10 a
crisis on Infinite Earths crossover
moment so they're actually filming the
crossover episodes right now Stephen
Amell himself just had his very last
scene with Grant Gustin ever it was an
incredibly memorable moment but he
posted this video of himself falling
asleep and snoring in the middle of the
scene when they were getting ready to
film between takes
he just joked that all these years
working together it was bound to happen
eventually it might as well happen in
their very last scene ever they will
drop the trailer for the crossover
sometime either at the end of October
beginning of November but we'll probably
see some promo footage in smaller bits
of scenes leaked out before that number
9 they open the actual episode with the
black market weapons crew getting
hijacked by their old boss controlled by
work without really realizing that
he's controlling the golem don't they
know they're in a horror story you don't
break the rules of the horror genre by
talking about the dead member of your
crew like he's never ever going to come
back takes him a little while in the
episode to actually explain what's
really going on but we're really meant
to get this from Ramsay Rose's
perspective because he still doesn't
totally understand how his powers work
but he is comic-book  work number 8
flash tells team flash about crisis on
Infinite Earths leaving out some key
pieces of information he even tells them
about the monitor but not everything
that the monitor said elongated man
refers to him as a guardian cost player
and everybody starts to freak out a
little bit about the date they spend
most of their time focusing on
frost arc because this is meant to be
her season of being frost more
than Caitlyn she doesn't want to die
before she has a birthday which they pay
off at the end of the episode before she
eats all 31 flavors of baskin-robbins
cube baskin-robbins joke it's just the
beginning of Barry checking off this
bucket list of preparing team flash all
the
members for a world without the flash
everyone on Team flash is trying to
prepare for what the anti-monitor is
they don't know who he is yet they just
know about the antimatter wave that's
going to erase everything but even by
the end of the episode
even though Barry's already made his
peace with everything he's just getting
ready to tell them that he has to die to
give them that Doctor Strange speech
billions of potential futures only one
where we all survive and it's the one
where I have to die 7 we meet Ralph's
mom she was kind of ridiculous during
the episode but it's all set up if you
couldn't tell for the SU didney arc
they're introducing that character but
that's gonna go into the back half of
the season they have a whole lot of
funny moments there's a whole bunch of
comic book references Marv Perez the
person that his mother is dating is a
reference to Marv Wolfman and George
Perez the two people who wrote and drew
crisis on Infinite Earths
in the comics all the other names of her
former boyfriends that he rattles off
are also the names of seminal comic book
creators there's Doug Mahnke Craig Young
and Nicholas Picardie the most important
part of all their scenes together was
that last moment where she's like go out
there you go out and find some love that
sort of meant to tee up to sue did in
the arc because she's sort of this
missing persons case that he's slowly
tracking down but it's gonna take a long
time for that story to percolate and we
might actually meet that character till
the back half of the season number 6
frost totally knows what's up
doesn't need to go through all the CSI
work to know that work is behind
all this even though she isn't really
looking at the evidence she's thinking
more about her memories of work
because she has Kaitlyn's memories she
also has all the knowledge that Kaitlyn
has so she's just as good of a biologist
and a forensic scientist as Kaitlyn was
she just has zero time for bullshit and
it takes bury the rest of the episode to
sort of come around to her conclusion
yes this guy is totally bad he was
totally trying to steal dark matter from
us
the way they leave things at the end of
the episode too is sort of a frenemies
situation where he rejects Barry's
attempts at friendship it come to me if
you ever want to talk no thanks I'm good
see you later but I think the reason why
they're pushing him on this villain arc
so fast is because he's only gonna be
around till right before the crossover
for like the first eight episodes or so
normally he would have a villain around
for the entire season and they would
wait a couple more episodes before they
go full-blown villain one of the coolest
moments from all their scenes together
though was number five the Blue Beetle
name-drop so he talks about Ted Kord I
got the dark matter from court
industries and Ted Kord
so clearly Blue Beetle is still alive in
a round on earth one very interested in
experimenting with dark matter
technology for some reason maybe we'll
get more answers about that later this
season but if you watched arrow for a
number of seasons you realize that
they'd actually been referencing cord
industries going back to arrow season
one and originally when Brandon Ralph
joined the arrow verse he was originally
supposed to be Ted Kord during arrow
season 3 Warner Brothers put the kibosh
on that because they were developing a
Blue Beetle Booster Gold movie that kind
of wound up in development hell that's
why they ended up turning Brandon Ralph
into Ray Palmer so just put a pin in the
fact that Ted Kord has been doing a lot
of stuff with Dark Matter technology
they also reference McCullough tech for
the Nash wells storyline McCullough is
the second version of mirror master they
used him a lot during season five
McCullough attacks so we'll see if we
see the actual second version of Mir
master on the show eventually number for
explaining Nash wells he's the new
version of Indiana Jones Harrison wells
which most of you probably picked up on
before Cisco literally said the words
Indiana Jones and Temple of Doom he's
meant to be more of a no-nonsense
version of Harrison wells like he calls
the Council of wells a bunch of
jackasses the more important thing
though is the black atom Shazam
Easter egg that he drops when he
references eternium so if you're not
familiar with that I know it kind of
gave off he-man and the Masters of the
Universe vibes are they talking about
he-man is that what's going on
no eternium is actually a DC Comics
element what it is though is it's
actually just shards of the rock of
eternity it was used during a Legion of
super-heroes storyline post zero-hour if
you don't remember zero-hour it was the
thing that came after Hal Jordan turned
into parallax and threatened the entire
multiverse it was kind of a follow up
story to crisis on Infinite Earths
before they did Infinite Crisis during a
legion of super-heroes storyline you
learned that the Legion is trying to
assemble all the pieces of eternium to
reform the rock of eternity so we'll see
what they end up using it for on the TV
show but that just means that there is a
version of Shazam in the rock of
eternity that existed at one point
during earth ones history whether or not
it's still around remains to be seen I
feel like with the success of the Shazam
franchise in the films in the black atom
movie coming up it was only a matter of
time before they started referencing
those characters in the arrowverse the
rock was actually just tweet
about the Black Adam movie is saying
that production will be starting next
July
he's more booked up than any other movie
person but he said it was a 10-year
journey so if you've been wondering how
long he's been working on this Black
Adam Shazam stuff he's been for the last
decade but when he was first signed up
he was actually initially cast to play
the Shazam character then during the
development process decided he liked
Black Adam better because of his origin
is a slave and how he rose to power
we'll talk about more Black Adam stuff
as they start to ramp up and announce
more of the cast and find out more about
the story that movie number three they
defeat the war golem using the
negative flash trick from the comics so
if you're not a big flash rebirth comic
book reader work is analyzing the
dark matter samples but learns that he
can control the golem
he hasn't completely figured it out yet
but he just knows that he has some level
of control over it
frost comes up with the idea to
defeat it by overloading it with dark
matter and that's what the negative
flash did to defeat comic book
work but because they use this twist on
the Golem and not the actual work
that means that when Barry eventually
has to take down Ramsey Rossa either in
episode a door before the mid-season
finale at some point they'll have to use
some different twist they won't recycle
this same twist from the comics the
other important thing to note is is the
more dark matter he absorbs the more
powerful he gets and it's probably
similar for work like he absorbs
all that material back into himself at
the end of the episode making him
stronger it'll probably continue to be
like that episode 2 episode in the
pipeline prison was not strong enough to
hold the golem in meaning that it'll be
a lot harder for the flash to take down
a supercharged version of work
before the mid-season finale number 2
was work figuring out how his
powers work by reabsorbing the material
back into himself the way they're
explaining it is is that his ability
combined with the of the other
person combined with dark matter is what
created the special new material that
he's taking back into himself they're
gonna double down on that in next week's
episodes we'll get to see him go a
little bit crazier but number one was
Nash wells finding the shards of the
rock of eternity in the post-credits
scene so the whole idea is is what is he
actually going to do with the eternium
this scene kind of gave me a
Ghostbusters 2 vibe to like the special
material they're looking for is somehow
flowing through the sewer system the
only other big thing the showrunner said
about his character is that he
storyline is directly tied in with how
they set up crisis on Infinite Earths
and obviously referencing eternium
shards of the rock of eternity seems
like a pretty big deal so that is crisis
level but if you spotted any of the big
easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
mention in the video just let me know in
the comments I will do more crisis on
Infinite Earths stuff in my trailer
video when I post that tomorrow for
episode 4 I know you got all kinds of
questions about what's going on with Tom
Welling Superman with all the Batman
stuff that they're doing during the
crossover it is gonna be crazy
so everybody click here for my last big
crisis on Infinite Earths Batman flash
teaser and click here for my brand new
Star Wars Episode nine trailer Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight